[Music]
Paula Deen might be like next door it's
a very strange situation she's in right
now now that the hammer came down
because now it's like all right the
executives got to be like all right what
is the because she's basically like a
hundred million dollar whale just
sitting there
that's a gambling thing she'll make you
hide a million dollars and she just
sitting there on the beach what is the
acceptable amount of time yes after
somebody drops the n-word or admits to
it that you can bring them back on TV to
make cookies yeah Dog the Bounty Hunter
lit up three months three months he got
a three month suspension and within
three months he was back on TV and some
of the guys he was chasing were
african-american and nobody had a
problem with so really weird citrus like
what you're saying is they put one of
these situations they said oh my god I'm
so sorry everybody says we want nothing
more to do with you and then the clock
is running
no first well first what happens is you
get caught and then you have the people
who are like professionally like
outraged
you know those people get on they can't
even get it out what kind of like three
days
you have to try to make some cockamamie
story up that you're not a psycho and
then you just sit there and you wait for
the phone to ring because you know you
can make people money like that's all
it's about like they should just have a
channel for people who screw up like
like can you just put him on that
[Applause]
understand firing somebody like that's
gonna make them like somehow help the
problem like a dude on ESPN he said that
stuff against gay people so it so then
he gets fired how does that help his
homophobia right now you put him out on
the street right he's out there drinking
booze you know he's probably saying even
more homophobic you know just put him on
a channel like the the disgraced Channel
is something right like the penalty box